Okay, and we're live, Georgie DeKalb, Ray Peat.
Guys, thank you so much for joining us today.
Thank you, Georgie.
Thank you, Ray.
And we're just going to rifle through a bunch of questions, but before we do that, how are
you, Ray?
Very good.
Yeah?
So the weather had gotten a little bit sunnier in Eugene, so that's always a positive.
It's going to be in the hundreds, over a hundred this weekend.
And then how do you, do you go sit in the sun or what do you do?
No, I'm going to stay inside all day, tomorrow at least.
We open the door at about 1 a.m. when it cools off, blow in some cooler air and then close
it up for the day.
The house is concrete, so it holds its temperature for about a day.
And blocking that 5G as well.
Yeah, yeah, a little bit.
Okay, and then Georgie, how are you, sir?
I really like your elevator music that you put at the start of the show.
It was very soothing.
Did you hear it through my headphones?
No, I heard the music.
Was I not supposed to hear it?
Oh, no, you weren't.
Okay, that's a little bit weird.
Ray, did you hear the music too?
Yeah.
Oh, okay, weird.
Okay, that's a new...
I thought it was kind of interesting.
You tried to hold a conversation over this really loud music and I thought, "Wow, that
must be a new feature."
That's one of the...
In conference call music.
That's one of the reasons we're upgrading equipment, because when I'm talking to you
guys before the show, I'm always hearing music and it's obnoxious.
Okay, enough of that.
This show, like I said, told you guys before, I don't feel like it's for me or necessarily
per se Georgie, although Ray and Georgie, you guys' interfacing and bouncing ideas off
each other is, I think, what the people are here to listen to.
Okay, so I'm just going to go through these questions and read them.
And Ray, some of this stuff is going to be redundant and answer as much or as little
as you want for all of this.
So our first one is from Drew F. and he says, "Trestosterone/MENT is not 5-alpha reduced,
but bodybuilders and some post-finasteride sufferers experience benefits in terms of
mood, anabolism, et cetera.
Is androgen receptor agonism a likely explanation for the effects?
It is a much stronger androgen than testosterone."
Which reduced testosterone is it?
Georgie, do you know what this is?
It's...
Yes, I know.
It's a new steroid.
It's 7-alpha-methylated version of nendrolone, which is a carbon-18 steroid of the estrein
family.
So it was...
I was always suspicious when they add the methyl group.
Yeah, it's actually very hepatotoxic.
As you know, Ray, methyl groups at position 17, 7, and potentially others, they've all
been proven to have severe hepatotoxicity.
But bodybuilders like it because I guess they don't value their liver that much, but also
it's the steroid that can achieve the same with lower doses and they think it's worth
it instead of abusing the testosterone in higher dosages.
That steroid was developed as a male contraceptive candidate, and I think it's still in clinical
trials for that.
But even the company that developed it and is running the clinical trials got discouraged
given the hepatotoxicity.
Ray, do you want to clarify the methyl group?
So adding a methyl group to a steroid is risky, you said?
Yeah, it just sends it off on unknown pathways.
The liver never had to deal with such things, and so I think it's extremely unpredictable
and dangerous.
Good stuff.
And then we've talked about post-finasteride a bunch, so I want to kind of get into that
again.
I kind of want to...
I think his main question was, "Is activation of the androgen receptor a plausible explanation
of the antidepressant and general feelings of well-being from using these androgenic
steroids?"
I think it's plausible.
Great stuff.
Thank you for that, guys.
Okay, Marcelo, this is just kind of a statement.
Thank you, Danny, for your contributions to the community.
You are a big reason why Ray's work...
Wealth of knowledge is available to us.
Thank you so much, Georgie, for his continuing curiosity and dedicating his life's work towards
advancements in this space.
Hope this helps.
Thank you, Marcelo.
Sincerely appreciate that.
Thank you to Ray for being humble and inspiration for all things.
Andrew Wallace says, "What would you do if you had Crohn's?
What would be your protocol?"
Me?
Yeah, Ray, I always assume...
I guess I'm just asking you, and then Georgie can chime in at any point.
Pretty much what I do anyway.
Assume that the intestine is my contact with the world, and I have to protect it, and so
I don't want to offend it in any way, and Crohn's disease is a seriously offended intestine.
And from what I've read, it seems like you've dealt with a lot of serious intestinal things
over the years, as one would in this environment.
And so it's not like you're speaking from reading...
I know you read, obviously, a lot, but you're speaking from personal experience.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I had Crohn's as a baby with migraines, which recurred every time I would do certain things
wrong up until my mid-40s.
I would still...
The last one, for example, was when I was visiting in San Francisco and didn't realize
that they had fluoridated water, and I would occasionally drink some of that water, and
I was taking Sinoplus or Sino-Male orally, and within two or three days, I had a tremendous
migraine, and that started me thinking about it, and fluoride can totally wipe out the
activity of T3 if it happens to be present in your stomach and the T3 is exposed to it.
Amazing stuff.
Okay, so obviously...
I have a question in regards to Crohn's disease.
Ray, have you seen some of the more recent studies claiming that Crohn's disease may
be caused by a type of mycobacteria, which is known to cause Crohn's disease in animals,
and now they're saying the same thing may be true in humans?
Yeah, but the inflammation and poor digestion are set up to conditions for such things to
accumulate and multiply.
So basically making sure that you don't irritate your intestine more than absolutely necessary
is at the basis of a protocol for keeping...
You can find a mycoplasm in just about any sick person.
It's sort of opportunistic and looks for a sort of place to live.
So maybe this antibiotic therapy that they're now trying in Europe for this potentially...
They're treating it as a bacteria infection, but it's really destroying the microbiome
and keeping the intestine sterile, which reduces the inflammation.
Not necessarily...
It's not only one bacteria, it's just...
This is helping because it's reducing the amount of bacteria in the intestine anyways.
Yeah, just taking a series of penicillin doses or eating raw carrots, for example, can have
very similar effects.
And in both rats and people, it turns out that anything that cleans up your intestine
will lower your cortisol and estrogen and increase your progesterone just because the
intestine is such a chronic drain and source of stress.
In regards to the carrot salad and in general fiber, what are your thoughts on supplementing
with pure cellulose if one could find a pure source?
It would be interesting.
They used to sell basically a cellulose tablet for weight loss.
I've never tried one, but it seemed like a good idea because cellulose doesn't have the
estrogen-promoting symptoms that a lot of other fibers do.
Yeah, the reason I'm mentioning is I was reading some studies.
They're using various cellulose esters as binders for drugs for developing pharmaceutical
drugs and some of these esters, like for example, ethyl cellulose, showed remarkable antibacterial
effects in animals and reduced inflammation.
So I thought maybe it's because it's clearing out their intestines somehow.
Oh, yeah.
It was a very popular laxative effect as well as weight loss.
Was this in the past, like in the maybe '60s or '70s?
I used to see the ads for it on TV as recently as 1986, I think it was.
Interesting, very interesting.
Speaking of cortisol, okay, this one's from New Health and they say good cortisol blocker
supplements for weight loss.
What is your thoughts on that, Ray?
What blocker?
Like a cortisol blocker.
Progesterone and pregnenolone are the best ones I know of, but working at the pituitary
level, a lot of things, sugar, aspirin, probably sodium, anything that stabilizes your blood
sugar and metabolism, reduces inflammation, will defend you against cortisol.
Thanks for that.
New Health says, "There's now a spinoff of the Ray Peat community with Morley Robbins
ideas, aka Ceruloplasmin.
Would you be willing to do a show on this from a Ray Peat perspective?"
I think these were when they originally thought that Georgie and I were just going to do a
Q&A.
Ray, what are your thoughts on Ceruloplasmin?
It's an acute phase reactant, so do you want to be increasing Ceruloplasmin?
Is that a goal of a diet or lifestyle or supplement routine?
Not my goal.
Do you want to comment on Morley Robbins?
You know who that is?
Are you familiar with their work?
No, no.
I have a question.
If somebody has low Ceruloplasmin, some of the studies claim that this is a sign of low
thyroid function.
In a situation like that, considering that Ceruloplasmin apparently takes care of the
copper and makes sure it doesn't become toxic to the various organs, would somebody be potentially
at risk if they have low Ceruloplasmin and low thyroid?
Would they be at risk when eating high copper foods like liver and shellfish?
I think so.
Did you ever read Carl Pfeiffer's books?
I think he caused himself to lose pigment by being so obsessive about keeping copper
down.
He was very concentrated on the risk of too much copper, probably having seen some people
with Ceruloplasmin deficiency.
Ann Louise Gittleman, Andy Cutler, and Carl Pfeiffer were all about copper toxicity.
It seems like from reading your work that they were misled in what they thought was
going on.
Yeah.
He took a little capsule of flowers of sulfur every day for many, many years.
He had no trace of skin or hair pigment left.
Okay, great stuff.
This one's from Joseph.
He says, "Can you speak about nitric oxide and the word on the street that it's good
for Cialis or Viagra, so that it works like those substances?"
I'm afraid there is quite a bit of overlap.
The initial, as soon as nitric oxide was discovered to be produced in the body, they were seeing
its involvement in everything degenerative and harmful.
Then when the Viagra came on the market, suddenly for about five or six years, everything published
was how great nitric oxide is, it prevents hypertension and protects you against everything.
Thousands of articles came out suddenly reversing it from a dangerous free radical to a cure-all.
Then about 10 or 15 years ago, there was a gradual return to sanity and realizing that
it's one of the very central things to degeneration, aging, the follow-up of trauma, estrogen interactions,
everything stress-related and degeneration-related involves the pro-inflammatory effects of ethanol.
Two follow-up questions.
One says, "Is aspirin safe to take every day and also is lactose-free milk?"
It doesn't taste very good, but I think it's safe enough.
It probably doesn't let you absorb nutrients quite as well as natural lactose-containing
milk, but I don't think it's harmful.
Then your thoughts on using aspirin every day?
Yeah, when I had a good supply, I was taking it every day very consistently, but sometimes
I forget to take it when it isn't in a convenient form, like some of it is powdered so fine
it's choking when you try to take it just on your tongue.
Georgie, interrupt me at any time.
Okay, this one's a little bit long, so bear with me for a second.
"I've been trying to have a baby for more than a year, but I have azuspermia.
Found after three semen analyses and undetectable levels of spurn after a testicular ultrasound,
they found a small varicocele in both testicles.
I've been taking seven to eight milligrams of extremistain for three weeks.
For how much longer is it safe to take?"
So this is the first question.
"Will continued extremistain use help me fix the varicocele as well as the azus-"
What's she taking?
Exemistain.
It's a steroidal aromatase inhibitor.
I'll just finish up this question.
It's like there's two more sentences here and we can go through it.
"If exemistain doesn't fix the azuspermia, what else can I do?
I'd like to avoid having a varicocele ectomy or even worse, surgical sperm extraction from
IVF.
After three weeks of exemistain, my total testosterone went from 400 to 756.
Exemistain has also increased my FSH and LH and are now above standard range.
I thought FSH and LH would go down as testosterone goes up."
So were there bits of that question that you have comments on, Rick?
Yeah, I think you can get a safer inhibition of aromatase using aspirin, progesterone,
completely safe things.
Thyroid is very important, but just with aspirin, progesterone, and thyroid, you can get your
ratio back, testosterone, pregnenolone up and estrogen down.
Supplementing pregnenolone and thyroxine historically was very effective for correcting infertility
and enlivening inactive sperms.
And so the azuspermia, if the cholesterol is high and the person wasn't taking enough
thyroid, that would be a result of that with high estrogen?
Yeah, the thyroid and pregnenolone make their energy-producing system revive.
Great stuff, thanks for that.
Okay, Peggy says, "Question for the Q&A.
Thoughts on ivermectin for COVID, prophylaxis, and any alternative as it is almost impossible
to get a prescription for it.
Thank you."
Prophylaxis suggests you would be taking some every day for an indefinite time until you
didn't get the infection, and the normal use of it is a very short course.
About one person in a thousand in the studies of using it to treat parasites will show signs
of brain damage.
I don't think it's a good idea to take maybe thousands of daily doses, even a moderate
amount of something that once in a while is known to cause brain damage.
There was some podcast that was talking about ivermectin and a bunch of people emailed me
about it the exact same time.
Again, Georgie, interrupt at any time.
Okay, so this person says-
I can give a few more, I mean, based on the studies that recently came out.
Methylene blue, a well-known antiviral, at least four studies came out in the last month
saying it can both prevent and treat COVID-19.
Of course, there's no medical advice, but that's what the study said.
Another hydroxychloroquine, you can try plain old quinine.
My personal favorite, hydroxychloroquine is just a patented, more liver-toxic version
of quinine.
Naringenin, also a few good studies.
So drinking orange juice should have similar effect than taking the isolated version.
And aspirin, vitamin C and vitamin D, I mean, all of these now have quite a few studies
behind them.
Unfortunately, everything is being censored by mainstream media, so you have to go to
PubMed to find them.
But I wouldn't say-
Ivermectin would be one of the last things I would try considering all the other safer
alternatives that are out there.
Cyproheptadine, famotidine, which is an acid blocker, but apparently is also a potent anti-serotonin
agent as well.
Really, I don't know where the Ivermectin craze is coming from.
Maybe that's the only thing that hit the mainstream news, but tons of other chemicals, safer and
cheaper and available over the counter that can do just as well, if not better, than Ivermectin
with fewer side effects.
Vitamin D is very effective.
There was a study done in Spain in a hospital which was withdrawn after a lot of doctors
wrote ignorant letters to the publisher.
For some reason, the editor caved in and had it withdrawn.
But it was very clear that they gave, I think it was 6,000 units, something like that, per
day.
Maybe it was 8,000 first dose and then 6,000 units a day to people who were admitted to
hospital intensive care, very sick with COVID.
Simply that treatment with vitamin D reduced mortality by about, I think it was 60%, just
an absolutely clear difference, but the readers who didn't like vitamin D quibbled that they
hadn't done statistics quite right.
But you can't miss a 60% disappearance of dead patients.
I would like to see a doctor argue that 60% more live people is statistically insignificant.
Very stupid people who are complaining.
A shout out to the Kate Deering and Kitty Blomfield podcast you did with them.
I thought it was like a tour de force and you at least, I thought you cleared up every
single anti-vitamin D argument that exists on the internet right now.
I was very thankful for that podcast and I think you can type in Kitty Blomfield, a win
at life podcast, vitamin D, Ray Peet, and a person can find it instantaneously.
Okay.
Hi, Danny.
Hi, Georgie.
Hi, Ray Peet.
Many thanks for the show.
Please keep going.
I have one question.
My 10 year old daughter has hypothyroid symptoms, low energy, weight gain, digestive problems.
Her TSH is between four and five and her free T4 is around 12.
Doctors here don't test for other markers, unfortunately.
Doctor says everything is okay and no need to worry.
Do you have any suggestions what we can do?
Preferably nutritional plus lifestyle.
Thanks again, Timo.
P.S.
I'm lucky you could take my question.
What do you think about that?
Very important to get the TSH down.
TSH at that level itself is causing symptoms, pro-inflammatory symptoms and it's going to
disturb her puberty development, all kinds of development and the history of that bizarre
attitude towards TSH, I think it's on my website, 50 Years of Fraud is part of the title.
There's just no scientific basis for relying on TSH, especially at such very high levels
as five.
And you know, just my limited understanding of things of reading through hypothyroidism,
the unsuspected illness, like he wrote, it talks about childhood hypothyroidism and it's
not crazy to investigate a thyroid supplement for a child, right?
Oh, not at all.
Sometimes it has started at a very young age.
It's increasingly important around seven or eight or nine when the first signs of puberty
are coming on because the estrogen is going to slow down the thyroid function.
Great stuff.
Okay.
This one's from JV Marketing and they say, "Hi guys.
I recently started taking thyroid 12.5 micrograms of T3 and 37.5 micrograms of T4.
I am day three into this and my waking temperature has been slightly lower than usual.
Is it normal for a slight dip in temperature before improvements are made?
Could this be a nutritional deficiency?"
You know, very low thyroid people will have, especially during the night, high cortisol
and adrenaline usually.
And you should check your pulse at the same time when you wake up along with the temperature.
And then after having a breakfast with, for example, a lot of orange juice, the stress
hormones are going to be decreased when you get your glucose level up.
The adrenaline goes down, the cortisol will go down.
Both of those have kept your temperature, both of them, and pulse rate kept up by high
adrenaline during the night.
And so by which of those changes the most, you can tell what night stress was responsible
for them and when you get your thyroid gradually improving your carbon dioxide production and
stabilizing your glycogen stores, your nocturnal stress goes down and so you're revealing the
hypothyroid condition that was hidden under the stress hormones.
During daytime testing, people who were very hypothyroid such as a 5 or 6 on the TSH level
have been very hyper and normal seeming, not fat or edematous or sluggish or anything,
but they were found to have 30 to 40 times the daily output of adrenaline making up for
the low thyroid production.
And so it's pretty common to have extreme slowdown when you start on your thyroid.
That's why it's so important to keep a chart marked off for at least 2 or 3 weeks showing
your temperature and pulse rate both on the same chart so that you can draw a line and
where it should with an ideal starting dose of thyroid, you should see the lines rising
steadily towards the goal of pulse rate and temperature at the end of 2 or 3 weeks.
But if at first you see the numbers going down, that's evidence that you're getting
out of the stress.
Great stuff.
Thank you for that, Ray.
Okay, this one's from Jean, mega super supporter of the show and she says, "I wanted to..."
A lot of these people are mega super supporters, "but I wanted to ask and hear more about why
people who are vaccinated are getting colds and flus right now.
There seems to be a lot of discussion in my neighborhood that people are out sick at work
and feeling flu/cold symptoms, even though it's extremely warm here."
The purpose of any vaccine is to create a systemic inflammation and in general that
weakens your overall immune system, even though it pumps up your specific antibodies, the
general inflammation is a weakness at least during the time you're having symptoms and
unfortunately sometimes for a much longer time such as the year after people have an
influenza vaccination, their rate of coronavirus infection was greatly increased, 50% of the
people were infected, 60% more likely to get infected by a different virus because they
were protected against influenza virus.
So the idea, the officials actually say stupid things like, "Get vaccinated, it'll make
you healthy."
Thanks for that.
And we'll take a break here, Ray, like, I don't know, like maybe 20 minutes or so because
I know this, I don't want to give you like a lobotomy from just asking you a hundred
questions, but I know...
I have a question about the vaccines.
Is there any truth to saying that basically the vaccines are sacrificing general immunity
in order to boost specific resistance to a very specific virus while at the same time
making you vulnerable just as you mentioned, you also mentioned influenza and corona, but
I think this applies to any virus, right?
If you shift the immune response, protecting from only one virus, you're exposing yourself,
becoming more compromisable to all the other viruses.
Yeah, there were, I think, 10 studies showing that with influenza.
Follow up, the whole doctrine, going back to Ehrlich's time, it's a drug industry-centered
theory of what immunity amounts to.
Paul Ehrlich was selling his patent drugs and he shared the Nobel Prize with Metchnikoff,
who was an embryologist who saw immunity as the whole organism maintaining itself, a total
inclusive concept of what immunity or resistance is.
Ehrlich proposed a theory that was ideal for selling magic bullet drugs.
The concept of magic bullet was converted to the antibody theory of immunity that your
B cells produce the specific immunity.
So logically, if you don't have a specific drug for every conceivable disease, then you're
going to need a vaccine for every existing or possible disease because the antibody theory
of immunity is really just a silver bullet, one drug to sell for one disease.
Great stuff.
Okay, this one's from James B. and he says, "Question," okay, this kind of trends on the
first question we talked about.
He says, "Question, if your lab rat was supplementing with pregnenolone, progesterone, and DHE,
and you had the task of building the most amount of muscle while somewhat preserving
your health, could you outline a potential stack you would use?
I was thinking about 50 milligrams of testosterone base along with 25 milligrams of masteron.
I know these aren't hepatoxic, but would you dissolve these in tocopherol and take sublingually
before swallowing for maximal effect?
P.S.
Your thoughts on low-dose trenbolone base?"
Even with natural testosterone, I think people are generally getting overdosed.
Very healthy, very young man might produce four or five milligrams of testosterone per
day and so one or two milligrams well-assimilated should give you a tremendous boost of virility
and muscle strength.
And with DHEA, the teenage production is 12 to 15 milligrams and so it goes steadily down
with aging similar to testosterone.
But by the time a person is 30 or 40, five milligrams will still bring them up to a normal
level of DHEA.
And the others, the overdose is apparently the desired state.
I have a question about the amounts of steroids.
Yes, a younger, young, virile man will produce four to five milligrams of testosterone, but
they also clear estrogen much more effectively than an older person.
So their testosterone to estrogen ratio or testosterone to cortisol ratio is pretty high.
An older person basically tends to be overloaded with both estrogen and cortisol while having
their testosterone levels.
So the four to five milligrams, yes, they will potentially bring up the testosterone
levels up to the levels of a young, virile man, but they won't necessarily fix the issue
with the high estrogen and high cortisol.
So that person may not be necessarily feeling the same anabolic or mood boosting or whatnot
effects that a younger person would get from such a dosage simply because their stress
hormones are too high.
And I think that may be why older people and bodybuilders in general, they're overdosing
these steroids simply because they're not addressing the thyroid angle and they're trying
to shut down their stress hormones by simply over flooding them and overcrowding them with
these androgens.
That's why that may be one reason why they're using such high doses.
For several reasons, thyroid is our basic anabolic hormone.
It directly activates protein synthesis, lowers cortisol and the breakdown of protein and
inhibits the effect of cortisol and inflammatory things on aromatase.
It's an aromatase and cortisol antagonist.
So basically an anabolic approach with steroids should always take into account thyroid, right?
Or at least some other option of blocking cortisol in a safe manner.
Yeah, as a basic anabolic substance.
The muscles, if they're under stress or in forced idleness, will cause the muscle to
actually produce and secrete cortisol and estrogen.
And when they're properly activated with thyroid and activity, they will be a source of testosterone
and a sink for cortisol.
Okay, great stuff.
Thanks for that guys.
Okay, so this one's from Craig.
He says, "Craig Doe, I've been diagnosed with severe sleep apnea induced by arterial
fibrillation.
I'm on meds that make me feel terrible.
Tried cardioversion, didn't work.
I'm 53 fit.
Use a CPAP.
Any ideas how to get off meds?
Thank you."
People who are using CPAP are almost always hypothyroid and low in progesterone.
For many years, they've been curing sleep apnea with prothyroid things and progesterone.
Progesterone lowers the stress hormones, improves the depth of sleep and maintains regular breathing
and prevents hyperventilation.
The real problem in sleep apnea is cyclic hyperventilation followed by cessation.
When you go deficient in carbon dioxide, your breathing stops and you could even die from
respiratory arrest if you are producing so little carbon dioxide.
So thyroid and progesterone directly corrects the problem.
Acetazolamide has been used, I think, for 50 or 60 years to treat sleep apnea and it
indirectly raises your carbon dioxide level and keeps stimulating your breathing through
the night.
Amazing.
Thank you for that, Ray.
This next one's from-
I have something to add.
Most drugs on the market currently for AFib, which is the common name for atrial fibrillation,
are blood thinners.
And the flagship drug known as Xarelto was approved by the FDA with the FDA's knowledge
that the clinical trials conducted in Mexico and other Latin American countries were 100%
fraudulent.
There's a famous article by the Slate magazine, which came out in, I think it was 2016 or
'17, where they did an exposé of how FDA knew that the trials were fraudulent, not
simply deficient, but fraudulent.
Data was made up to support the approval of the drug.
And when Slate and other journalists tried to contact FDA, basically FDA refused to comment
on it and threatened the journalists that they will sue them and impose a gag order
if they continue walking around and talking how Xarelto is a dangerous, potentially murderous
drug.
So I would try to get off that drug because there are many other safer blood thinners.
A subsequent trial was done outside of the United States, I forgot where, but it compared
aspirin to Xarelto and found aspirin to be more effective and safer.
So I think Xarelto may be causing a lot of these problems, especially with the lowering
of carbon dioxide.
It's really not a safe drug.
Wait, you're saying the pharmaceutical companies are corrupt, Georgie?
I'm saying the FDA is corrupt.
Okay.
I had never heard that before.
That is wild.
Okay.
Thank you for that, Georgie.
Thank you, Ray.
Where was I?
Okay.
This was from Mohammed and he says, "Question for Dr. Ray Peet.
My mom is borderline diabetic, removed thyroid, and has pain in her feet that bothers her
a lot.
What can she do to treat this?"
What was her thyroid condition?
I think she had it removed, he said.
Oh, well, the doctors likely prescribe thyroxine, and in women, thyroxine fails to be activated
properly because of estrogen interfering with liver function, which should account for about
two thirds of your active thyroid function.
So for most women, thyroxine being what doctors like to prescribe just isn't correcting the
problem.
And so getting on a real thyroid supplement is essential when you've had the gland removed.
And maybe you feel confident in ARMR in the US right now?
I haven't tried any ARMR in recent years, but I haven't heard any new bad things about
it.
For several years, they were going back and forth, failing FDA tests and so on.
But for several years now, I haven't heard bad things about it.
So it's the only glandular right now that I would trust.
But during the time that ARMR was being reformulated in the early '90s, I shifted to the synthetics.
First, Thyrol-R formulated by ARMR to exactly imitate natural ARMR thyroid, and then Sinoplus,
which exactly imitated the Thyrol-R formula, and made by the same company that makes Sino-Mal
or Pure T3.
And so those have been very reliable now for at least 30 years.
Thank you for that.
Amazing stuff.
Okay, we're coming up on 45 minutes or so.
Thank you, Ray.
Thank you, Georgie.
I sincerely appreciate you guys making this show possible.
Harrison, huge, gigantic donation.
Thank you so much, Harrison.
Thank you.
Thank you for making all this possible.
Matthew T., also another extremely generous donation.
Thank you, guys.
And then we'll move on to these super chats.
Maybe we'll take a quick break here, Ray.
And maybe we can talk about Progest-E, just a millisecond.
So 3,400 milligrams of progesterone per bottle dissolved in vitamin E. You can email Keenogen@gmail.com,
aka Catherine.
And you can...
She'll ship it extremely fast.
She just shipped me 12 bottles of it.
It's sitting in my refrigerator right now.
And Ray, do you want to dip into your gigantic bag of positive progesterone stories and say
anything about it?
Oh, no.
Nothing occurs to me right now.
Okay.
One thing you said on the vitamin D with Kate Dearing and Kitty was you didn't really think
of it like a hormone.
It's just this generalized stabilizing factor in cells.
And so I think you've said that before, but that resonated when you talked about it.
That was like a...
The brain is a major source and goal of progesterone.
And men have just as much in their brain, or should, as women.
And it's involved in the cell division process all the way up to nerve and muscle function.
Every conceivable thing in higher animals depends on progesterone.
Great stuff.
Thank you for that.
And if you're at gmail.com, you can message Catherine and she's very nice and she'll send
out the progesterone very quickly.
So thanks to Catherine.
Thanks to Keenogen.
Okay.
Nick P174 just donates $10.
Thank you for that, Nick.
Rising Stronger for 999 says, "For Dr. Pete, I've heard you mention milk and fruit as the
cosmic diet and wonder if there is an ethical component to how you view and structure your
nutrition.
Thanks to the three of you."
Yeah.
It has to do with cosmic entropy, actually.
It's why the whole energy concept of existence involves the cephalization process in all
animate beings.
And you can trace those processes of increasing consciousness and brain development through
the physics of the universe.
It all has to do with creating order, maintaining order.
And it happens that milk and fruits are the simplest and most order-preserving way to
integrate your life with the cosmos.
I love it.
Thanks for that, Ray.
Okay.
This one's from Umar.
And they say, "Does a benign tumor have a similar metabolism to a cancerous one?
I have had a benign osteochondrodroma on my upper femur since childhood.
What ways/supplementing can help in removing it?"
Thank you all.
If it's quiescent, not inflamed or growing, no, it doesn't have the cancer metabolism.
It's just a structural defect.
But any inflammation, according to the degree of the inflammation, is going to start having
the cancer metabolism.
Great stuff.
Thanks.
I wanted to mention rubbing progesterone on it, since it's simply a fibrotic structure,
may help a lot.
There's some older studies that seem to have stopped around the '70s that kept calling
progesterone the most potent anti-fibrotic chemical known to man.
And they suddenly stopped.
I guess the pharmaceutical industry got involved.
But they had success in animal studies by applying progesterone topically or subcutaneously
and managing to dissolve multiple metastases of much worse and malignant tumors.
So I don't see a reason why it couldn't be applied in this case as well.
The anti-fibrotic effect, I've seen examples of hundreds of times.
I think the reason they stopped talking about that effect is that the mechanism involves
interfering with estrogen's pro-fibrotic effect, activating nitric oxide and serotonin.
That group of inflammatory things, estrogen, nitric oxide, and serotonin, are all blocked
by progesterone.
And those are the pro-degenerative, pro-fibrotic substances.
Great stuff.
Thanks for that, guys.
This one's from James.
"Guys, I've had man boobs for years, which recently developed into gynecomastia, but
only on my left breast.
Is there a way to reverse this?"
Thank you.
Just today I got an email saying that his chest fat and gynecomastia regressed thoroughly
from taking quite a bit of progesterone.
But I think it's essential to use vitamin D and thyroid and all of the anti-aromatase
substances, including some aspirin, to keep it under control.
Amazing.
Great stuff.
This one's from another James.
They say, "When approximately did the United States transform from a constitutional republic
into an empire, or was the USA always set up to be one from the beginning?"
Well, the spreading from the colonies across the continent, taking the Western United States
away from Mexico and then following that up with war against Spain to take the Philippines
and Cuba, the imperial mentality goes back right almost to the beginning.
But the 20th century has been steady imperialism with the banana republics being kept in line
with sending battleships every year so they would threaten another country in the hemisphere.
And there was a temporary let up with FDR's good neighbor policy, or as good as we are.
Ray, are you still there?
I just actually—
Yeah, he's there.
Okay, I just lost everything.
Okay, we're back.
Sorry about that.
Go ahead, Ray.
Sorry.
Well, it has just grown in its intensity.
Starting right at FDR's death, policies were absolutely 180 degrees reversed where he had
planned a post-war anti-imperialist policy.
He had a conference with Wendell Wilkie.
They agreed that whichever party won after his term was up would follow the decolonization
anti-imperialist world policy.
But it happens that Wilkie got a cold and died at a very young age.
And then just before Roosevelt could find out that Alan Dulles was committing treason
and outlying himself with the German intelligence, Galen system, to take over the world, Roosevelt
died just before he could learn that fact.
And so immediately with his death, the Dulles faction took over with a single-minded imperialism
that had been followed steadily.
Great stuff.
I'm getting told that the audio is a little bit wonky, but I guess we're just going to
have to keep going here.
I don't know what's wrong.
This is why we're trying to buy new equipment.
Okay.
Where was I here?
Nick says, "Hey guys, say a guy lost the ability to ejaculate and then also slowly over a period
of a couple of years was also basically unable to get an erection.
What things would be the most important to look into?"
Doing blood tests would be very useful to see what your cortisol and estrogen, DHEA,
testosterone and thyroid and testosterone are doing.
Great.
Yeah, I want to add to that that sometimes doctors will just test the testosterone, but
several large human studies show that you can have erectile dysfunction and ejaculatory
problems and fertility problems, even in men with normal levels of testosterone and DHEA,
as long as either prolactin or estradiol are either elevated or in the top 25th percentile
of the "normal" range, which we know it's not really normal.
Great stuff, guys.
Thank you.
Okay.
This one's another from Nick and he says, "My heart rate is in the low 50s while sitting,
but while standing and also resting, it's in the 80s.
Should the sitting be close to the 80s causes?"
I think it should be higher than that, unless there's some reason.
If you have a really big heart, it can pump a lot of blood with pulses as low as 50, but
ordinarily you aren't pumping enough blood to keep things in very good health if it's
running that slow.
And that would just be a general sign of hypothyroidism?
I think so.
Great stuff.
Okay, Space 99 Yak says, "Is the herb Boutilla Superba Root good for DHT?"
I've never heard of it.
Any thoughts, Dr. Ray?
I'd have to look it up.
I mean, I don't know.
I've heard of the herb, but I don't know through what mechanism it would be good for
DHT.
I know nettle root is actually a drug in Germany and they're using it to treat prostate problems.
And they kept saying for years that, "Oh, it's because it lowers the androgens."
And then it turned out it actually contains aromatase inhibitors and is raising DHT instead
of lowering it.
Great stuff.
Okay.
This one's from Gaza Mongo and they say, "Can the thyroid be damaged with exogenous T3?
Is the feedback loop shutting the thyroid down activated by a certain amount daily or
per dose?
I.e., could small doses be additive rather than a replacement?"
If you get as much thyroid function as you need, the gland should adjust itself.
It's always responsive to signals such as adrenaline and TSH.
You can shut the TSH down completely and then if you stop shutting it down with the large
doses, it pops back very quickly.
I've seen my own thyroid gland when I was taking 50 micrograms of T3 per day.
I developed holes about as big as my index finger on each side of my Adam's apple between
that and the muscles.
And so I stopped taking the T3 for just a day or two and immediately within 24 hours,
my neck had leveled out.
The gland swells and shrinks according to need.
So a lot of doctors will talk about suppressing or damaging your thyroid gland by supplementing
because their reasoning from what happens to your adrenals or testicles if you overdose
on one of the hormones, high cortisol or glucocorticoid use can cause your adrenals to shrink to
the point that if you suddenly stop the supplement, you might die from the absence of adrenal
production.
But the adrenals will gradually over about a month recover if you are well nourished
after you've totally suppressed them with too much cortisol.
The thyroid gland only takes a day or so to completely recover.
Thanks for that, Ray.
Kana?
I have a question about pregnenolone and the adrenals.
As you know, Ray, the older studies in the early 20th century showed that when you give
people under stress pregnenolone, it decreases their output of 17 ketosteroids.
Isn't that a sign of potential partial adrenal suppression by pregnenolone or is it simply
giving them a break?
I think it's applying whatever function they were producing so they aren't needed.
In the study of rats, they measured their cortisol production and other hormones and
found a normal variation.
Most of them were normal.
A few were hyperproducers of cortisol but they gave them, I think it was 10 grams of
injected, a stomach full of powdered pregnenolone and then studied their hormones.
There were no endocrine changes that they could detect except in those which had been
under stress with high cortisol production.
Their cortisol went down to normal receiving those gigantic doses of pregnenolone.
So the person basically that's under a lot of stress, pregnenolone, doesn't just have
an anti-cortisol effect but it also gives the adrenals what they need, gives the adrenals
a break, I guess for lack of a better word.
Yeah, the adrenals and gonads are potentially self-regulating.
The pituitary is just there for an additional boost.
When Han Selye was experimenting with removing adrenals, he found that after the tissue-stored
steroids had dissipated, just a moderate amount of stress would kill the animals because they
didn't have the adrenal resilience to meet the stress where the ordinary rat would die
from a little bit of a stressful situation.
He noticed that the pregnant rats didn't even notice, had no ill effects from an increased
adaptive stress and so he experimented removing the adrenals and supplementing progesterone
and they lived a normal lifespan with no adrenal hormones at all.
Progesterone supplement totally replaced all of the adrenal hormones, aldosterone and cortisol
in particular.
Have you seen any studies that discuss the effects of pregnenolone specifically on the
pituitary?
I know there are a lot of studies by Selye and others.
Only that old 1950s study in which cortisol was corrected.
So you think pregnenolone does have a direct effect on the pituitary?
Yeah, the same way that any anti-stress substance, progesterone or sugar or aspirin for example
will stop the exaggerated pituitary activity.
Great stuff, thanks for that guys.
Okay, this one's from Joshua and he says, "My wife is 24 years old experiencing low
libido and hot flashes after having our second child.
What can be done to bring her sex drive and energy back?"
Generally, thyroid is the thing that you have to check the whole nutritional pattern.
Not getting enough calcium and vitamin D interferes with your mitochondrial energy production
regardless of your thyroid status.
So drinking milk, taking vitamin D, drinking orange juice and maybe supplementing thyroid
would be the usual thing to do.
Thanks for that, Ray.
This is from Kana for 2,440 yen and she provides a sticker and I can't really tell what's
going on there.
Thank you for that, Kana.
No question there.
Okay, so Space 99 Yak says, "Your thoughts on how to reverse the aging process and increase
health span.
The basics and advanced stuff that you might not talk about as much."
Carbon dioxide, very important for stopping the stress and degenerative processes and
vitamin D, calcium and thyroid and progesterone are part of their function is to normalize,
optimize the balance between carbon dioxide and lactic acid.
I have a question about carbon dioxide.
You talk about in your articles, it's actually a Lewis acid and you also talk about partial
oxidation, putting the cell in an oxidized state.
It has a structure similar to the quinones.
It's much simpler but it does have those two carbonyl groups.
I'm not aware of any direct reaction in the organism where carbon dioxide actually directly
takes an electron and becomes reduced in the process.
How does its electron withdrawing function work in the organism?
The inductive effect, wherever it's attracted to an electron rich area, those electrons
sort of bulge towards the Lewis acid that has an electron attracting effect.
The bulging of those electrons by induction through the carbon chain reduces the electron
availability two or three carbons down the line.
The whole electronic quality of the whole protein molecule is affected in a shift towards
positivity or relative electron deficiency.
When you're full of CO2, all of your proteins have that shift and the flavonoids from orange
juice and milk and lots of fruits and vegetables, they can, by partial oxidation, like vitamin
C inside the cell, becomes oxidized and then becomes an electron recipient.
The flavonoids become similar electron attractors and shift the whole structure of the cell
into that relatively partial electron deficient state.
That affects, through the inductive effect, one protein has its influence on surrounding
proteins.
So the whole system is a cooperative electron slightly deficient condition, an acidic condition.
In other words, the whole cell turns into an acid.
So a more specific example, let's say you have a molecule of NADH, the reduced version
of NAD, it's the electron carrier.
So the presence of high amounts of carbon dioxide, would they be able to directly oxidize
NADH back into NAD or would they have a more indirect effect?
Indirect, shifting the whole system, activating the electron transport chain, turning off
lactic acid production, shifting the balances everywhere towards reducing lactic acid and
NADH and glutathione, shifting it towards the oxidized balance.
And the flavonoids, looking at their structure, they actually are capable of becoming fully
electron withdrawing agents, right?
They will actually be able to oxidize the NADH back to NAD.
Yeah, that seems to be why things like fisetin have an anti-aging effect.
They turn off the inflammation and stress excess of electron production.
And one of the ways you have to think about it is that this isn't a static condition,
it's a pressure of electrons flowing.
There are electrons in motion between the energy source and the electron consuming cytochrome
oxidase.
So if you think of the Venturi effect in gas or water, the pressure goes down as the speed
of flow increases.
And so what thyroid and these pro-oxidative substances do is to accelerate the flow of
electrons, decreasing the risk of random lipid proxidation by escaped electrons because
as the flow increases, the pressure, electronic pressure decreases.
So the whole cell becomes shifted away from electrons towards oxidation.
So in theory, combining carbon dioxide, whether, I mean, raising carbon dioxide and having
the presence of these direct electron withdrawing agents would be even more therapeutic.
Yeah, so I don't think anyone knows what the upper limit of oxygen consumption is, but
health and longevity, as far as anyone has tested, will increase as that flow rate increases.
Have you seen that recent study on fisetin being a very effective senolytic, I think
is the word, senolytic chemical?
Yeah, I think it's more than that.
I think it can actually correct the inflammatory process and not have to kill the cells.
Do you think things like naringenin, apigenin, other similar flavonoids would have similar
effect?
Yeah, a lot of them have been tested, for example, for preventing or treating radiation
sickness, the ultimate in electron excess disease.
And they're very powerful in protecting against or curing radiation injury.
So it sounds like a glass of orange juice and a little bit of vitamin B1 would be a
great combination as an anti-aging agent.
Yeah, probably every few minutes a glass of orange juice.
Great stuff.
Thanks for that, guys.
Okay, Space99Yak, or you know what, there's another one about ivermectin.
We kind of already talked about that, but they say, "Can ivermectin help protect against
the harms of the spike proteins modified by the AstraZeneca DNA vaccine by occupying spike
protein receptors?"
I don't know if that connects between ivermectin and the receptors.
We said earlier that was a risky substance, and so it's like combining two risky substances
together, basically.
I think a safer method would be trying to raise the levels of the ACE2 enzyme, because
that's what the spike protein binds to, if I'm not mistaken.
Right, that's the medical establishment got it exactly backward, and the things that increase
the ACE2 substance and the 1-7-antitransfer fragment, which is the result of ACE2 action.
Those are increasingly recognized as the therapeutic and curative agents.
And so everything that we know of as protective against COVID involves the increase of the
1-7-antitransfer and the ACE2 enzyme that produces it.
I found a very interesting study showing that progesterone directly increases, and quite
dramatically, the levels of ACE2, while at the same time lowering the amount of ACE.
So it should have like a double punch effect, like protecting both from COVID and potentially
the spike protein.
Of course, there are many other bad things in the vaccine, but I think progesterone seems
promising based on that study for protection against at least the virus.
Yeah, and it's safe to use all the time, preventively.
Do you think it may help?
I mean, I know there are studies about progesterone and influenza.
Have you seen any studies about progesterone and other viral particles?
Yeah, it actually has some antiviral or anti-replication effects, stabilizing the cell, makes the virus
not have any support for replicating.
Thanks for that.
Okay, Space 99 Yak says, "Any way of getting rid of acne scars?"
Depends on the scars, like if it's still inflamed, sort of like a slight keloid, vitamin E and
progesterone applied to it can shut off the production of inflammatory things like estrogen
and nitric oxide and restore the tissue to more or less normal so it loses the inflamed
appearance.
I have another thing to add.
There's a human study showing that a 4% niacinamide solution, separate studies actually, one used
4% niacinamide solution in water.
The other one used 1% aspirin solution in water.
Both of these help to reduce the formation of scars, even in severe acne.
I think combining them into one solution, 4% and 1% would probably work even better.
Great stuff.
Okay, this is from Ellie and they say, "Morning temps not budging, but day temps improves
on thyroid."
Why?
Morning temps not budging, but day temps improves on thyroid.
So they're taking thyroid, they're...
Go ahead.
That's pretty good.
While you're lying in bed, hypothyroidism isn't doing so much damage.
So the important thing is to keep the numbers optimal and steady during the daytime.
Thanks for that.
Thanks Ellie.
Thanks Ray.
Janet Pack, again, another...
A lot of these people are chronic supporters of the show, but she just sent a sticker for
$50.
Thank you so much, Janet.
DBO514 for $10 says, "Get yourself some gear, son."
Thank you so much, DBO514.
Kirk says, "What's the best strategy for someone with diabetes with swollen purple legs and
significant water retention?"
Thank you all.
I would start with vitamin D, getting adequate calcium, normalizing thyroid progesterone
and pregnenolone.
And then when you get your metabolism steady and some of the edema reduced, then shifting
the diet chronically, probably decreasing total protein somewhat to keep your total
fat intake lower.
Any kind of reliance on fat for energy is going to interfere with your sugar use and
the thyroid and calcium and vitamin D are going to help restore your ability to oxidize
glucose.
Thanks Kirk.
Thanks Ray.
Teresa and Diana both sent super chats, but no questions.
Thank you, Diana.
Thank you, Teresa.
Another one from Space Jack.
They say, "Best med/supplements to increase mitochondria and mitochondrial function."
Carbon dioxide is essential and very powerful for that.
And so all of the things that support oxidative metabolism are going to shift you towards
the better supply of carbon dioxide.
And the antitension inhibitors are starting to be recognized as supporting mitochondrial
energy production, reducing inflammation and degeneration.
So the boutique supplement of breathing into a bag.
Yeah.
Okay.
Kirk has another question here.
He says, "My 67 year old mother has one 1.2 centimeter nodule on her thyroid.
Her TSH is 2.5, free T4 1.0.
However, her TPOAB is 32.9 IU/ML, which is well beyond the 5.5 limit.
What would you suggest to correct the nodule?"
Thank you.
Which one was high?
TPOAB, thyroid peroxidase.
Is that what it is?
TPOAB, 32.9.
Oh, correcting the, getting the TSH down to something like 0.4 would be tremendously helpful.
Thanks for that, Ray.
Thanks, Kirk.
Cornelius says, "Any thoughts on how to treat excess saliva?
It happens whenever I eat, I get massive excess saliva.
Foods high in choline, eggs, et cetera, are a lot worse, I think.
It is a cholinergic crisis."
Often getting your thyroid going helps to shift your balance towards sympathetic adrenaline
activity and suppress the parasympathetic.
Thanks for that, Cornelius.
Thanks, Ray.
Zachary says, "16 year old, breast cancer, received radiation, had a lupine, lumpenectomy,
had a couple, had a couple lump scars since now, lump scars since.
Now 19, what remedies would you recommend to help prevent it coming back?"
Lower estrogen/corazole?
Sure.
Thyroid, vitamin D, and aspirin are very powerful protectants against estrogen and cancer development.
Thanks for that, Zachary.
Thanks, Ray.
Cornelius has another one.
He says, "Does Ray have any thoughts as to why taking supplemental T3 may cause a negative
change in body odor?"
Negative being worsening?
That's what I assume.
Yeah, it can increase your sweat production.
Just taking one or two showers with 10% sulfur soap can eliminate permanently a bad balance
of bacteria on your skin and can make a difference in the odor of your body, the sweat for a
long time.
Thanks for that, Ray.
Thanks, Cornelius.
David says, "What are your opinions on nicotine as a pro-metabolic substance and is there
some overlap with nicotinamide?"
No, I don't think there's any overlap that I've ever run across.
What about you, Georgi?
Do you know of any overlap?
I don't know of any overlap.
I think there is some evidence that nicotine in low-dose, well, actually, there's some
studies showing that it's a powerful aromatase inhibitor and there's some other components
of tobacco leaves such as cotinine, which is structurally similar to nicotine, but they
all seem to activate the adrenergic, the sympathetic system when overdone.
The animal studies that I've seen that showed protection for Parkinson's disease, Alzheimer's
disease, heart disease, and cancers, they use the equivalent of one to two milligrams
daily, which is half a cigarette.
I think most people that use the nicotine gums or the patches, they consume drastically
more and it becomes very quickly becomes a stress agent.
At least that's what I've seen.
On the excess saliva question, I should have mentioned that the things that promote the
sympathetic system, such as atropine or even the anticholinergic effects of ciproheptadine
and the antihistamines are likely to help.
Great stuff.
Thanks for that, guys.
Awesome.
Okay, Victoria says, "How do I lengthen my menstrual cycle, both follicular and luteal
phase?
I'm 26 years old and my cycle ranges from 23 to 29 days with 26 being the average."
That seems close enough, but increasing the thyroid level will lower the estrogen and
sometimes that will make it click into a very standard 28-day cycle.
I've never seen any bad effects associated with a variation of only 26 to 29 days.
Great stuff.
Thanks for that, Ray.
Okay, our buddy Comrade James for $30, "US, but no question."
Thank you, Comrade James.
Francis Bacon Cheeseburger says, "Recommendations for daily progesterone routine for a male
in their 30s?"
If you don't have any symptoms, I think just a drop or two of progesterone or maybe 5 milligrams
has a probably protective general stamina increasing effect.
We get a lot of people saying they're taking, men taking 20, 30 milligrams, you know, like
in they seem to be doing really well on it and that seems to be some, George and I are
both constantly inundated with that anecdote.
So that is very interesting.
Yes, sometimes that's enough to shrink a man's penis temporarily, but for others, because
it inhibits conversion of testosterone to estrogen, sometimes it's powerfully libido
promoting pro-testosterone, but it's very individual.
I get emails all the time from men over 50 saying that they're using 100 milligrams from
progesterone and they recovered their morning erections, which they had lost like 20 years
ago.
Very good.
Thanks for that, Ray.
And thank you, Francis Bacon Cheeseburger.
Okay, I think that's the same question we already talked about with James.
Zach says, "Do people typically experience negative symptoms during the process of reducing
endotoxin, cortisol, serotonin, or estrogen, i.e. getting worse before they get better?"
I always doubted that.
That's an old medical trick.
I give you my personally compounded drug and you get very sick.
That's evidence that it's curing you.
When you get sick after a vaccine, that's evidence that it's working, they are saying
now.
But that's been a constant, centuries-old ploy of the medical industry to say you have
to get worse before you get better.
Yeah, when they cut, burn, or poison you, you're going to get worse first.
Or at least they're saying, "Look, we actually gave you something that does have an effect.
It's not a placebo."
Isn't there like a name for this?
I think it's called like a Hertzheimer reaction or something like that?
Yeah, that's basically the same thing, a medical invention to defend the harm they do.
So the heroic therapy for cancer is basically an extreme version of that.
They kill you in order to save you.
Yeah, the statistics show that the survival rate has never been improved by surgery, radiation,
or chemotherapy as a whole.
Individual studies are constantly showing it.
But if you added up the thousands of individual evidence of benefit, it would be very strange
that on the whole population you see, if anything, a slightly worsening of the outcome.
I'm just refreshing my page here so I can get more of the super chats.
Who was the guy, Harry Rubin, Henry Rubin, the guy that went across the world and he
found that treating cancer was of no value at all, at least by standard medical procedures?
Yeah, I was at a seminar, 1969 I think, a world conference on the immune system.
He and a beginning Oregon instructor in biology were the only truth-oriented people there.
All of the big shots from around the world were there and they were all doing their phony
thing.
And Harry Rubin and this young professor, no one listened to them very much, but they
actually had facts and supported evidence and interesting stories that showed the falseness
of what all of the immunologists were doing.
Amazing.
We have about 30 more minutes here, so we'll rush through these, not rush through, we'll
try to get through as many questions as possible.
Ray, Pete, thank you so much for doing this.
Sincerely appreciate it.
Georgie Dinkov, thank you so much for being my partner in crime and always doing all of
these and making the show what it is.
So thank you to both of you guys.
Thank you for our amazing listenership, which is extremely dedicated and loyal and sincerely
appreciate all of you guys so much.
Okay, so Jordan for $5, no message.
Thank you so much, Jordan.
Elliot Cactus says, "How is THC and CBD understood in the bioenergetic view of health?
Any recommendations, dietary supplements/drugs/lifestyle for regular marijuana users?"
Oh, THC, was that the question?
Yeah, how is THC and CBD understood in a bioenergetic view?
I've been looking for the real beneficial effects and it's always very ambiguous as
far as I can see.
It is sedative and in some circumstances anti-inflammatory, but not always.
And for many years I haven't been able to resolve the ambiguity to have a definite opinion.
Thanks for that.
Elliot, go ahead.
One more thing for me to add.
A study from 2017 came out, demonstrated that pregnenolone can antagonize most of the intoxicating
effects of marijuana, which is probably not what people are looking for.
They're trying to get high on it.
But also animal studies subsequently show that it can protect from some of the anti-androgenic
effects and estrogenic effects of marijuana as well.
So I guess if somebody is using heavily marijuana and wants to continue to use it, which I don't
think is a good idea, but if that's their thing, the human equivalent of about 30 to
50 milligrams of pregnenolone based on the mouse study seems to be able to block most
of the negative effects and some of the positive if sedation is your thing.
Thanks for that guys.
Appreciate it.
Okay, David, boy for $4.99.
No message.
Thank you, David.
Jordan.
Okay, this might've been his question.
He says, "Preparing for dark days ahead, what supplements should my wife and I have on hand
and how do you recommend storing us dogs, chickens living in MN?"
Is that in Minnesota?
Minnesota.
Yeah.
Dark, dark days in what sense?
IE, cyber attacks, BLM infiltration in your home.
You know, I guess all the things we're chronically talking about.
Food chain.
Yeah, food chain disruptions and things like that.
Having some stable calorie supplies and some protein, if the crisis comes, you're going
to want to share your supplies with the people who didn't stock up so the quantity that you
put away should be economical and long lasting.
We happen to have a barrel or two of coconut oil and it's always good to have a few 20-pound
bags of sugar and maybe 40 pounds of gelatin powder on hand.
Great stuff.
Great suggestions.
KBP.
Quick question about the food.
Have you seen, Ray, have you seen that Walmart sells this thing called Astronaut food supply
and they're basically commercializing what NASA did in the '70s.
Basically it's powdered eggs, dehydrated milk, sugar, and I think they have some kind of
a starch, which I don't remember what the source of that was, but basically they claim
it's a complete diet that can last for a century at room temperature and they're selling three
months, six months, 12-month supplies.
Do you think there's any value in getting those dehydrated eggs and milk or do you think
it's dangerous?
I've always wanted to have a good supply of powdered milk on hand, but I've been having
trouble finding out exactly how they prepare the particles that don't clump and I've been
afraid that they're using nanoparticles as anti-clumping agents and so for the present
I would not rely too heavily on that.
What about evaporated/condensed milk, which is sold in cans?
You're basically getting the equivalent of a gallon of milk in a small can?
Yeah, I think that's good to have.
The can might eventually deteriorate, but it'll last quite a while and maybe some canned
sardines.
Great stuff, thanks for that.
Okay, KBB for $9.99, no message, thank you so much KBB.
New Health again says, "I seem to get a low, a lump in my throat feeling and itchy spots/hives
on my body from Sinomel/Sinoplus.
Any solutions?"
How fast was it taken?
That's sometimes the problem.
If you try to correct the problem in just a few days or a week, that can cause the gland
to shrink so much that you get discomfort in your throat.
Interesting.
And we talked about it a little bit earlier, I think this is probably worth clarifying,
how much do you think is too much at one time with food?
For a T3?
Yeah, T3.
With a meal, 10 micrograms is probably the maximum that you want.
Otherwise it shouldn't be over 5 micrograms at a time.
The meal will spread it out quite a bit and make it a steadier supply.
And last question for me, would you feel confident swallowing that tablet that it would dissolve
in the stomach or would you chew it?
Oh, I always chew any tablet.
It helps you know somewhat what it's made of.
Is there any benefit in taking thyroid with fat, the long chain fats, in order to go through
the lymphatic system instead of mostly going to the liver?
I think as it digests, it's going to distribute itself.
The amino acids that are more hydrophobic might get taken up in the chylomicrons.
Great stuff.
Thanks for that, guys.
Okay, Tom says, "I've had numerous people note the development of varicose veins with
pregnenolone and progesterone use.
Please could Ray comment on this?
Thanks all."
I would question the quality of the supplement used first because their biological functions
are just the opposite.
I've seen horribly bulging veins normalize in an hour with a big dose of progesterone
and more slowly with many big doses of pregnenolone.
I think someone who got bad products reported that and started people thinking about it
and then if they don't get immediate improvement, they think they might be getting worse.
I wanted to add something to that.
It's very important to make the distinction between varicose veins and more well-defined
veins.
Sometimes people when they have edema, you can't even see the veins, even the contours
on their hand or their legs and when they take progesterone or pregnenolone, the edema
rapidly decreases and then the veins become more visible.
That's not the same as varicose veins.
I've never seen a person develop varicose veins from pregnenolone or progesterone.
Yeah, the effect when you get enough is exactly the opposite.
For example, a big vein known to be so bulging that it can't possibly have any valve action
with a very big dose of progesterone, the muscle can be activated to the point that
the vein narrows and the flaps of the valve on each side of the vein can then reach each
other and close off the flow.
What would you consider a big dose in that context?
It depends on how high your estrogen is.
If a person has very high estrogen, it might take 400 milligrams of progesterone, but that
amount would knock some people out.
And we're talking orally, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you think there's any benefit in taking a lower dose orally to avoid the sedation
and rubbing, I guess, the other half on the actual vein?
Yeah.
Putting it optically on while taking a moderate dose is probably the best approach.
Great stuff.
Andy Congo says, "Any critique on the croissant diet?
Claims SCD1 causes obesity and sugar raises that.
It's a low PUFA, super high saturated fat diet."
Whose diet?
What diet?
There was a study showing eating a ton of French croissants, which basically were baked
with almost fully saturated fat, but also, of course, a lot of starch in them, led to
a drastic weight loss and improvement in health.
The sucrose itself, some experiments show that you can increase the metabolic rate by
20% just with sucrose.
And so when you do it just right, sugar is a very powerful weight loss instrument.
Great stuff.
Thanks for that, Ray.
Okay, we're heading to the end of our time here, but I'll keep reading these.
KT has no message.
Thank you so much, KT, for your donation.
Yodi the Wodol says, "Alcohol in terms of capitalizing on the social libidinal economy.
I recently realized I wasn't drinking enough.
What amount is best for lipofuscin?"
I wasn't drinking enough.
That's great.
Vitamin E is known to be fairly effective at clearing up lipofuscin.
Progesterone is effective.
The amount of alcohol that can clear it up is very small.
Something like a gram or two a day is enough to have a helpful effect on lipofuscin.
Space99yak again says, "Georgie said the outer layer of the adrenal gland atrophy.
Is there any way to reverse that if that happens to someone and any way of knowing if it has?"
Adrenaline and progesterone both help to protect the adrenals so they can regenerate.
What I meant by that comment was that with aging, the layer that produces DHEA and pregnenolone
tends to atrophy and then the only one that remains is the cortisol producing one.
Ray, what was that guy?
He has a series of excellent papers on this subject.
I think Parker, do you know who I'm talking about?
He studied this in depth.
He doesn't ring a bell.
No worries.
Okay, last few questions here.
Spencer says, "30 male, low total cholesterol, 116 to 119 and low DHEA for the last 10 years.
Got the cholesterol up to 166, cutting starch, using the carrot salad, increasing sugar,
fructose and calcium.
Have all hypo symptoms, but my temps and pulses are normal.
Any advice?"
Why?
Not on any thyroid.
What kind of symptoms are hyper?
I'm not sure what that means.
Maybe I misspoke.
He said hypo.
I think this person had gynecomastia.
I think he had thinning hair and I think he had a kind of classical, I can't remember,
maybe constipation as well, but kind of like classical types of hypo symptoms.
And temperature was normalized?
I think he was reading them on a, they were higher like through the day, but in general,
I think this person felt terrible.
Checking for anything pro-inflammatory in the diet would be a first step to see if the inflammation
was interfering with their function.
Wouldn't sometimes very high cortisol and serotonin produce like a high body temperature
at the expense of destroying the muscles and everything else?
Yeah.
The stress hormones generally rise when your thyroid is low and it takes quite a while
when you're under stress to adapt fully to the thyroid supplement.
So Bruno Barnes over his career learned that it was best to aim for three or four months
for full correction with thyroid and people got so impatient, they think of correcting
efficiency as sort of a matter of a day or two, but it really, since the whole system
has to evolve in a different direction under the better energy supply, you should look
at the timescale of something like three months.
Yeah.
I think he has a whole section on that in his book, like what to expect and when, and
when changes will occur and when they won't.
Great stuff.
Okay.
Andrew Gassile says, "Thank you.
Tyromax is the bomb.
I can sweat again."
Thanks, Andrew.
Oscar Gomez for $5, but no message.
Thank you, Oscar.
MercyMe for $9.99, but no message.
Thank you, MercyMe.
Ben, he says, "Take more of my money."
Thanks, Ben.
Carlos Rangel for just a sticker, but no message.
Thank you, Carlos.
Carlin Brooks for $25, but no message.
Thank you so much, Carlin.
And let me just refresh this page really quick.
And while I'm doing that, Ray, what are you working on right now?
Not working on anything, but thinking about some of the old themes, giving them a new
perspective.
So, atherosclerosis and estrogen, for example, something related to that is going to be my
next newsletter.
Speaking of the older views, since Metchikoff was an embryologist, do you know of any field
in medicine or science in general that's still retaining some of those views and teaching
them to the younger generations?
No, they were all effectively erased from the profession by the mid-1950s.
And so, a few of the very young people are starting to look around and might be hope
for the future.
I can't believe this.
We're probably going to get through the questions here.
So, guys, we have 187 people watching.
Please give this episode a like.
I know it's arbitrary, but it really helps with the show.
Again, thank you to Ray for sitting here and being barraged by questions for two hours.
Sincerely appreciate it.
Thank you, Georgie Dinkov, again, my partner in crime, making this all possible.
So there's just a few more questions.
Maybe we can get through these and just call it a night.
Okay, so I mentioned Karlin.
This one's a scout.
And they say, "Do you think magnetofection could have been added to the COVID vaccine
to facilitate the mRNA getting into the cell?
Could that explain all the magnetic videos on the internet?"
I don't think they had to add anything.
The naked nucleic acids have no problem getting into cells.
I think they were calling the lipid coat a necessary way to get it into cells.
But when they've compared lipid-encapsulated DNA molecules with free DNA, in some situations,
the free DNA works better than the lipid-encapsulated forms.
And I think the real situation is likely to be that the so-called lipid carrier is really
a powerful adjuvant, a source of inflammation.
Thanks for that.
Another sticker from Fuhiha.
Thank you so much for that.
Peggy.
Hey, Peggy.
She says, "How to use progesterone to postpone menopause."
Thank you.
Oh, just using it cyclically is the important thing so that your liver doesn't get in the
habit of excreting it too fast.
So you have to lay off for one or two weeks every month and stay on cycle with it.
I've mentioned before that I met a gynecologist who was in his 70s and he had this very young-looking
wife.
He said that I've been giving her progesterone every month for 20 years and she's still menstruating
at the age of 63.
That's amazing.
Okay.
This one's from Nancy.
She just sends a sticker.
Thank you so much, Nancy.
Space99, yuck, again for...
He says, "The benefits..."
Talk about the benefits of allopregnanolone.
It's mostly what progesterone does.
It's one of the important conversion products in the brain, a neurosteroid.
And so everything we think of progesterone doing to mood perception, stability, stopping
seizures, helping with psychosis, it's really partly the effect of the allopregnanolone.
Amazing.
Thanks, Space99.
Thank you, Ray.
And the last...
All right, maybe we have three questions left.
This one's from Gregory and...
What is the time here?
Okay.
This one, Gregory says, "For the last few years, my father has developed excessively
dry palms to the point they crack and the flesh is exposed.
Doctors don't know what the cause is and just prescribe ointments.
Any ideas?"
Thank you, Ray.
Check his thyroid.
It's responsible for both sebum and sweat production in the skin.
If your thyroid is low, your skin almost invariably gets dry.
Okay, the absolute last two questions here, and then maybe we can talk about some cultural
stuff if you don't have to go, Ray.
But this is from Zach.
He says, "How to tell sugar is converting into carbon dioxide versus lactic acid?"
You feel very good.
You might feel panic and anxiety to the extent that it's turning to lactic acid.
Thanks for that, Ray.
Thank you, Zach.
Okay, the last question here.
Kirk, he says, "Hi, Ray.
I think I have heard you mentioned in a talk that 1,000 calories a day while still getting
all the RDA protein as well as for vitamins and minerals is an effective short-term way
to lose weight in the short term.
Any truth to this?"
Yeah, it isn't good for your health if you have to lose weight.
Keeping the minerals up is very important.
Calcium, magnesium, potassium, and sodium are very protective against too much of the
stress reaction.
I just have a related question.
They're now starting human studies with the drug RU486, which you have an article about
mentioning that drug, Ray.
And it's basically, even though it's known as the abortion pill, it was developed as
a cortisol blocker.
That was its original design and purpose.
And now they're having several clinical trials showing sustained, rapid and sustained weight
loss by using anywhere between 300 to 600 milligrams of that thing daily.
Do you think something similar can be achieved with progesterone instead of messing with
the diet and drastically reducing the calories?
Yeah.
Carefully adjusting your thyroid and progesterone and DHEA, pregnenolone, those can sustain
a very high metabolic rate, increased body temperature so that you burn calories much
faster.
So Dr. Bagniewski basically said, "How to burn fat while eating the Ray P. inspired
diet I gained 10 pounds."
And so it kind of intersects with what we were just talking about.
What should be the focus if a person is gaining weight?
Not to eat too many calories first and then to gradually shift towards a lower fat intake,
whatever keeps your temperature up without having an excess of calories.
And as your temperature stays higher, you'll be burning more calories and able to eat more
and more up to maybe 3000 calories a day for a sedentary person without getting fat.
Thanks for that.
And Goalie Ag doesn't have a question, but they donated $20.
Thank you Goalie.
And then Space Yak again donated more cash.
Thank you so much Space Yak.
We're going to call it there.
Ray, I don't like keeping you more than two hours.
Is there anything specifically interesting that you feel like needs a spotlight shined
on that's happened through medical or cultural or anything like that?
Or do you have to go and we can also just let you go?
Well, more and more kids are dying right after getting vaccinated.
So I think more people are starting to think in terms of murder rather than coincidental
deaths when they get sudden swelling of the heart that kills them.
I think the public is slowly starting to wake up.
Didn't the CDC like stealth edit their page or something and say that kids actually did
not need vaccine when they had been promoting the idea for a period of months or so?
Yeah, they said that very openly.
And then the reaction from the press was such that they erased it from their website.
And someone who mentioned the original statement that kids don't need the vaccination, his
comment was censored as contrary to Facebook's policy.
So in effect, the World Health Organization was censored by Facebook.
And people might not tolerate kids dying as much as they would just older adults.
Yeah, everyone is fine with when 80 or 100 percent of the people in the nursing home
die right after getting vaccinated.
But when a 13-year-old kid dies suddenly three days after his second vaccination, people
are starting to question authority.
And then this is not won't be surprising to you, but I did peruse a paper.
It was something like 84-year-old man autopsy after first Pfizer vaccine.
And the gist of the paper was something like all of his vital organs contained the, what
is it, like the RNA, the viral, the spike protein or something.
And so again, just more confirmation of everything you've been saying since March of 2020, that
this whole thing is a total charade and it's not localized and that it likely killed this
person like 18 days after.
And I guess this was like a landmark because it was the first autopsy of somebody who'd
been vaccinated.
Yeah.
And people should keep remembering that influenza was effectively wiped out by the surge in
so-called COVID deaths, meaning that the total pneumonia deaths didn't change.
Do you think, have you seen some of the new proposals in Congress and Senate to break
up and rein in big tech?
Do you think there's any, I don't know, honesty to these efforts or do you think it's all
a game?
To rein in what?
The big technology companies censoring people left and right and basically destroying society
as we know it?
It's hard to imagine that person surviving a breakup of the computer industry and Facebook
and Amazon.
That's such a totalitarian system.
I doubt that she's going to be able to accomplish anything.
So basically the empire really depends on for its survival on the big tech complex.
So any attempt to subvert that will probably be met with brutality.
I would guess so.
And then last question, any thoughts on impending cyber attack, you know, cyber polygon, the
world economic forum, it's going to happen next month and it's not rare for these things
to go live after a month or two, you know, is there anything you're doing right?
Like how would you survive if infrastructure and things collapsed?
After a while, I'm sure I would end up in Mexico.
But you don't really depend on the internet to live a productive life, do you?
No, not at all.
So it may be a blessing in disguise.
You'll simply go back to pen and paper and calling people on the phone and meeting them
in person.
Yeah, sort of hoping that that will happen actually.
Yeah, it'd be kind of counterintuitive for the system that sustains the ignorance to
be turned off.
But some people are saying people would go like psychotic within a week or two.
Do you think there's any truth to that?
No.
Well, unless you define psychotic as contact reality.
There may be a withdrawal period, a period of like abstinence or something.
But I also agree.
I think people will quickly discover how much they've been duped and how much they don't
want their internet connection back.
Yeah, including throwing away their cell phones.
Okay, great stuff.
I won't hold you any a bit longer.
Stay on the line.
We'll just say thank you again.
So Ray, thank you so much for doing this.
Georgie, thank you so much.
And we have an amazing listenership and I'll stay up after this and I'll do timestamps
for all these questions and things and sincerely appreciate all the support.
When you see us again, I think we'll have a souped up system and it will be very nice
and my computer won't be overheating and on the verge of collapse every single time we
do this.
So guys, thank you so much.
A special appreciation to Ray for just two hours answering questions.
And Georgie, thank you again and thank you to our amazing listenership and audience.
Have a safe weekend everybody and we'll talk to you guys soon.
Okay, take care.